Tate recently converted to Islam and a
lot of people lit my DMs up with stuff
about converting and information about
it I got some DMS on it too plus the
thousands of comments on them did you
get any bad DMS are all nice DMS
everybody was nice to me everyone was
nice to me and all the comments on that
YouTube video were really nice everyone
was nice I can say that was more
communication with individuals who are
Muslim than I can than I've ever had in
my life like yes I've worked with
Muslims and I've uh you know interacted
in in public settings with Muslims and
you know it's all been pleasant but
actually having somebody give me their
direct thoughts and I responded where I
could as much as I could that's the most
I've ever had and I and I can say that
it's all been really kind and pleasant
everyone's been really nice we have
sought to understand nature and our
place in it in this quest for the
purpose of life many people have turned
to religion most religions are based on
books claimed by their followers to be
divinely inspired without any proof
Islam is different because it is based
upon reason and proof
there are clear signs that the book of
Islam the Quran is the word of God and
we have many reasons to support this
claim
their scientific and historical facts
founder Quran which were unknown to the
people at the time and have only been
discovered recently by contemporary
science
the Quran is in a unique style of
language that cannot be replicated
this is known as the inimitability of
the Quran
there are prophecies made in the Quran
and by the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him which have come to I'm not
saying that there isn't proof of the
things in the Quran I don't know [ __ ]
we've talked about that but there
actually is proof of almost everything
that was written in the main gospels in
the New Testament about Jesus and his
life there's tremendous amount of proof
and I started learning about it through
through a movie that was based on a book
that which is a true story about a
journalist named Lee Strobel who went in
um he didn't believe in God and his wife
found God and it was ruining their
marriage and so because she found God
and he didn't yeah and they were
atheists and he was like this is what we
agreed what the hell you're doing and so
uh he went out on a and he was an
investigative journalist and he went out
on a mission to prove that she was wrong
so we could get his wife back and he
couldn't do it and deeper and deeper he
got all he found was more evidence that
the gospels were true and that it all
happened the way it was told and there's
tremendous evidence of and I would like
to you know expand on that except I I
don't have that knowledge like at the
top of my brain but watch the movie the
case for Christ that's actually a really
good movie anyway but a lot of it is
laid out there at least the important
points so it's not the only religion for
sure that has proof I didn't pay
attention in school
it's on me they didn't teach us that in
school
the following are some facts found in
the Quran
number one origin of life
water is essential for all living things
we all know that water is vital to life
but the Quran makes a very unusual claim
we made every living thing from water
will they not believe
in this verse water is pointed out as
the origin of all life
all living things are made of cells we
now know that cells are mostly made up
of water for example eighty percent of
the cytoplasm basic salmon cereal of a
standard animal cell is described as
water and biology textbooks the fact
that living things consists mostly of
water was discovered only after the
invention of the microscope
in the deserts of Arabia the last thing
someone would have guessed is that all
life came from water number two damn
that's crazy so it said that all things
come from water in the desert and then
that wasn't even scientifically proven
to thousands of years later who wrote
the Quran Quran oh Muhammad separated
the Quran in a piecemeal and gradual
manner from ad610 to 632 the year in
which he passed away evidence indicates
he recited the text and scribes out
excuse me okay where did he get that
Knowledge from was it from God so he's a
prophet he got these messages direct
from God I guess when God seems like the
last prophet I mean that someone dm'd me
that so obviously I'm not a master on
the Quran that's something I saw that
Muhammad is like the last prophet to
spread the word of God yeah I'm not up
on mine they all believe in Jesus though
did you read those comments I did read
those comments and I would like to do
more research on that keep going busy
day iron is not natural to the Earth
it did not form on the Earth but came
down to Earth from outer space
this may sound strange but it's true
scientists have found that billions of
years ago the earth was stuck by
meteorites these meteorites were
carrying iron from distant Stars which
had exploded
I did not the Quran says the following
on the origin of iron
we sent down iron with its great
inherent strength and its many benefits
for humankind
God uses the words sent down for iron it
is clear from the verse the iron is not
an Earthly material but was sent down
for the benefit of humanity
the fact that iron came down to Earth
from outer space is something which
could not be known
by the Primitive science of the 7th
Century how do we know that it came from
space is that what you're going to ask
what are you going to say no I think
he's probably going to get to that you
know scientists discovered that at some
point I don't know a lot of the
astronomy and astrophysics and all those
things don't look at me for that answer
that is interesting but if this is true
what a Pity I mean yes we've used iron
for some good things but man we've used
it for a lot of bad stuff too yikes
don't we need iron like in our like
bodies to survive yeah we do so that's
interesting and maybe it's just because
it was delivered here it became part of
our there's there's probably so many
questions all these questions are
probably answered but maybe that it
became part of our bodies at some point
where it became a necessity our bodies
have evolved number three Sky's
protection
the Sky plays a crucial role in
protecting the Earth
the sky protects the Earth from the
lethal rays of the Sun
if the sky did not exist then the sun's
radiation would have killed off all life
on Earth
it also acts like a blanket wrapped
around Earth to protect it from the
freezing cold of space
it's pretty cold
if this temperature was to reach Earth
then the planet would freeze over
instantly
the sky also protects life on Earth by
warming the surface through heat
retention Greenhouse Effect and reducing
temperature extremes between day and
night
these are some of the many protective
functions of the sky
the Quran asks us to consider the sky in
the following verse
we made this guy a protective ceiling
and yet they are turning away from our
signs that [ __ ] is crazy like just from
a science standpoint like there like
wasn't the sky we would just be like
like the Earth would just be negative
250 degrees and radiation would get us
all that's some simulation [ __ ] that's
wild pretty bad here but I guess that's
why you look to God you're like well
none of this [ __ ] makes sense there's
some divine power one of the biggest
things that stuff when we go into
religious high school was like the first
movement have you read have you heard
about that it's like something had to
have been the first movement like
something had to have happened first to
set everything else up to keep going
when I was a kid we learned the big bang
no isn't that like the big bangs isn't
that just a theory like is it it's
called The Big Bang Theory well that's
the name of the show no but isn't it the
thing it's like actually a theory like I
don't think it's actually like 100 yeah
here's how [ __ ] our world is you type
in Big Bang and and the sitcom came up
is the big bang a theory or law read it
out loud the Big Bang is an explanation
of the early element of the universe
according to this Theory it's a theory
Universe expands so we don't even know
for sure
reading that but yeah and then it said
you know condense down and then [ __ ]
molecules and [ __ ] like that if we can
trace everything back to that Big Bang
Theory what what what was before that
you know what if there's some first
movie if God is the god that I think he
is he is smarter than all of this
science and he created it that's the
Brilliance of it so yes we could both be
right is the point you've got people
fighting over the Big Bang Theory versus
God Evolution versus
um creation and what if we're all right
you know it's it's pretty cool if God
made it and then the evolutionists you
know have have watched it from a
scientific standpoint it's awesome
you're a fight over the dumbest [ __ ] on
this [ __ ] planet there was a thing
today Nat Geo came out we've reached
eight billion people on the planet
really yeah it's a lot of [ __ ] people
the headline was like we've reached 8
billion the earth now has eight billion
humans what now like let's get the [ __ ]
out of here getting way too crowded way
too crowded when the Thanos snap I'm
going work you know what the Thanos snap
is right no it's the Marvel superhero
that he came to the universe to kill
half of life to bring balance to the
universe no we need Thanos we need we
need Elon Musk to get some of us out of
here number four mountains oh [ __ ] the
Quran draws our attention to a very
important characteristic of mountains
did we not make the Earth as a resting
place and the mountains as Stakes the
Quran indicates that mountains
like oh I feel dumb
by using the word Stakes to describe
them
in fact mountains do have deep roots and
the word Stakes is an accurate
description for them a book titled Earth
by geophysicist Frank press explains
that mountains are like sticks and are
buried deep under the surface of the
Earth
Mount Everest the height of which is
approximately nine kilometers above
ground has a route deeper than 125
kilometers
wow the fact that mountains have a deep
stake like Roots was not known until
after the development of the theory of
plate tectonics in the beginning
that shit's crazy that's cool but like
what do you justify as like Roots so
like with the tree you know like the
roots literally come out from the tree
and they go out for miles and stuff
which is pretty [ __ ] sick I guess
like plate tectonics like different
layers and stuff of metals and [ __ ] I
wish I remembered all the things I
learned in all the years I went to
school because I remember learning about
plate tectonics but it ends there ah
they just make it so bad like so they're
like this it wasn't really necessarily
boring but I mean enough years go by if
you don't keep studying [ __ ] you forget
it yeah so like you know if they're the
place on the Earth are like this and
then they crashed into each other how do
you even test that like 130 kilometers
and then they go they they go up and
this this surface of the Earth and they
go up there's still parts of the plates
that go down and they must be basically
what we're seeing in mountains is just
the tip of the iceberg number five it
expansion of the universe
at the time when the science of
astronomy was still primitive
the expansion of the universe was
described in Quran and it is we who have
built the universe with our creative
power and keep expanding it
the fact that the universe is expanding
was discovered in the last century
the physicist Stephen Hawking in his
book A Brief History of Time writes the
discovery that the universe is expanding
was one of the great intellectual
Revolutions of the 20th century the
Quran mentioned the expansion of the
universe even before the invention of
the telescope number six wild sun's
orbit
that's just too much of a bug out like
how am I supposed to understand the
universe is the thing of infinite empty
space or not empty but full of random
stuff space and it's expanding but what
it where is it expanding to what's
what's the what's there what's there
isn't that also Universe bro the biggest
mind [ __ ] like you know whenever you're
baked or whatever and and you really you
sit around with your friends and talk
about it like it's like time time just
like infinitely goes back and it
infinitely goes forward time literally
just keeps going back like there's like
there's nothing that happened first
because something was going on before
that how could something have just
happened first do I need to get high for
this conversation no but I'm saying that
this is the [ __ ] I think of but it's
like what like what could have happened
first like there's nothing that could
have happened first because there's
something before that did [ __ ] just like
spawn out of like what like what the
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] have you ever had a
lucid dream where you know you're
dreaming yeah you said you do you fly
last night but last night I had one
while I was fighting to wake up and I
couldn't and I was terrified and I knew
I was having a bad dream and I was
trying to call you on the phone and I
was pressing the phone and it wouldn't
light up because I was still dreaming it
was bad but then I was like oh no I'm
dreaming and I had a fight awake you
know what's weird fly in my dreams but I
don't always know that I'm Dreaming I
had my first lucid dream that Saint like
like right after ever like that was like
my first time where I was like right
after what like after I said like are
you okay I came in your room and [ __ ]
and then I went to sleep I went back to
sleep and I had a lucid dream for the
first time it was wild I tried to be
Spider-Man and I was trying to shoot
webs because I was like I don't know I'm
in a dream and that's just like where my
mind goes it's like I gotta do something
cool so I was like trying to shoot webs
and I like couldn't and then I just went
and I was like smoking cigars with some
some guys I know online it was weird it
was like such a weird dream but you knew
but I knew but then it's like you forget
and like you forget and then you
remember yes you get caught up in it
again and then you remember yes it is
very weird [ __ ] that was crazy though
I've had you get you must get the you
have very active dreams and so do I you
must get that from me I can't take a nap
without a drink ever since I quit weed
I've had like the most vivid dreams like
I when you when you smoke and go to
sleep you don't even remember them like
every night I'm like almost excited I
always dreamed as a little kid too every
night I'm like excited to go to sleep
because my dreams have been so crazy
lately until wild stuff sun's orbit
in 1512 the astronomer Nicholas
Copernicus put forward his theory that
the sun is motionless at the center of
the solar system and that the planets
revolve around it the belief that the
sun is stationary was widespread amongst
astronomers until the 20th century
it is now a well-established scientific
fact that the sun is not stationary but
is moving in an orbit around the center
of our Milky Way galaxy
the Quran mentions the orbit of the Sun
it is created does everything stay in
the same spot how does the moon stay the
same exact distance like our gravity
doesn't stay the same exact distance at
different seasons it's closer and
further but like exactly it doesn't have
a circular orbit it has a like an oval
right how the [ __ ] is there a rock
that's floating around our planet that's
crazy like our like our gravitational
pull reaches that far to where it legit
holds this random Rock in the sky but
what if it had a [ __ ] Sarge and it
just pulled the moon and it just punched
Us in the face but like how crazy it
stays like relatively the same distance
like this [ __ ] rock is just floating
around us that makes no sense
let's get a really smart person on here
to dumb it down I'm just like so the
moon it's just like going around us
talking about this it's just but you
know when you're smart like I understand
why but it's like that's why those
people don't hang out with the rest of
us because we can't the Sheep they we
cannot think at their level oh yeah the
Sun and the Moon each floating in its
orbit
what did this just say did it just say
that the sun moves yes no the sun in our
in our galaxy stays and we go around in
the sun the sun moves in in the galaxy
and then it's like this is moving and
then everything around we orbit around
the Sun but the sun is moving itself
yeah and we're still just staying
relative to the sun is that is that it
yeah we're just relative to this ball of
gas
relative to us okay okay oh God I just
got smarter thank you the Quran would
have been wrong according to astronomers
just a couple of decades ago but we now
know that the quranic accounts of the
sun's motion is consistent with modern
astronomy
number seven the ocean oh
the Quran uses imagery to convey its
deep meanings hero describes the state
of the unbelievers as Darkness out in a
deep ocean which is covered by waves
above which are waves above which are
clouds layers of Darkness one upon the
other when one puts out his hand therein
he can hardly see it those God gives no
light to they have no light
it is commonly thought that the waves
only occur on the surface of the ocean
however oceanographers have discovered
that there are internal ways that take
place below the surface of the ocean
these waves are invisible to the human
eye
and can only be detected by specialist
equipment
the Quran mentions darkness in a deep
ocean above which are waves above which
are ways then clouds above that
this description is not only remarkable
because it describes the internal waves
in the ocean but also because it
describes Darkness deep in the ocean
a human being can dive no more than 70
meters without breathing equipment light
is present at that depth but if we go
down 1000 meters it is completely dark
one thousand people they know that yeah
there were no submarines or Specialists
to flip them to discover internal waves
or their Darkness deep inside the oceans
number eight lying in movement
there was a cruel oppressive tribal
leader named abujal who lived during the
time of prophet Muhammad peace be upon
him
God revealed the verse of the Quran to
warn him no indeed if he does not stop
we will seize him by the forehead his
lying sinful forehead
God does not call this person a liar but
calls his forehead the front part of the
brain lying and sinful and warns him to
stop
this verse is significant for two
reasons the first is that the front part
of our brain is responsible for
voluntary movement this is known as the
frontal lobe a book titled Essentials of
anatomy and physiology which includes
the results of research on the functions
of this area States
the motivation and the foresight to plan
and initiate movements occur in the
anterior portion of the frontal lobes
the prefrontal area the part of the
brain that is responsible for movement
is said to be seized if the man does not
stop secondly numerous Studies have
shown that this same region frontal lobe
is responsible for the lying function of
the brain
one such study at the University of
Pennsylvania in which volunteers were
asked questions during a computerized
interrogation it was found that when the
volunteers were lying there was
significantly increased activity in the
prefrontal and pre-motor cortices
frontal lobe region the front part of
the brain is responsible for movement
and lying fun fact I learned this in
science class in seventh grade a way
they track this is wherever your brain
is using the most activity that's where
blood goes so if you're lying and
they're tracking your brain they can see
where the blood goes through like the
scanner [ __ ] it's amazing that's how
they can tell neuronal activity is
linked to blood flow I smell so smart in
seventh grade when I learned that I was
up there on stage I was like yeah
neuronal activity is linked to blood
flow and everyone's like what yeah no
big [ __ ] deal Lynx movement and lying
to this area these functions of the
frontal lobe were discovered with
medical that's crazy equipment which was
developed in the 20th century
it's very cool number nine pain
receptors oh God
for a long time it was thought that the
sense of feeling and pain was dependent
on the brain
however it has been discovered that
there are pain receptors present in the
skin
without these pain receptors a person
would not be able to feel pain
consider the following verse on pain
we shall send those who reject our
Revelations to the Hellfire
when their skins have been burned away
we shall replace them with new ones so
that they may continue to feel the pain
God is Almighty Holy Father okay I'm
sorry like right here this is not nice
because if I don't believe you I gotta
go to Hellfire you burn off my skin then
you just keep giving me new skin and
burning it off and burning it off and
burning it off like that where's the
love that I'm hearing that's not loving
well it tells the people who reject the
message that when they're in hell and
their Skins are burnt off so they can't
feel any pain he will give them new
skins so that they continue to feel the
pain but the Quran makes it clear that
pain is dependent upon the skin the
discovery of pain receptors in the skin
all of this was such a nice peaceful
video and then they're talking about
Hellfire and I know the Bible does that
in places too and I'm fighting that [ __ ]
either I'm sorry these are just some of
the many facts found in the Quran it is
important to know that the Quran is not
a book of science but that is consistent
with science
to claim that scientific facts in the
Quran are due to coincidence would be
irrational
the best explanation is that God
revealed this knowledge to the Prophet
Muhammad
just like the Quran contains knowledge
about the natural world it also contains
information about the inner dimensions
of our souls
it relates to our feelings wants and
needs
the Quran informs us that we have a
purpose in life and that following God's
guidance will lead us to an inner peace
in this life and Paradise in the
hereafter
and that rejection of his message will
lead to depression in this life and Hell
Fire after death why do we got
we got Hellfire stuff I mean seriously
can't I agree with like the defining
purpose like is important and if you
don't you lead to you know that leads to
depression because obviously if you just
go down like the hedonistic black hole
that's also yes but yeah obviously like
if you just no yeah I agree like if you
just keep going down that [ __ ] you're
not going to find purpose and be truly
happy but yeah I agree the Hellfire
stuff is pretty crazy I mean I'm sure we
have to like look more into it but that
sounds like [ __ ] yes is that like do not
learn all the things we need to know
about about Islam it just now obviously
that's like holy [ __ ] it's just my
mind's being blown because like I don't
know I've always had such a warped
perception of the whole religion like
forever I think it's because of like the
way the media portrays it and with 911
and stuff like that and you kind of just
always have that weird bias I mean and
it's just taking the time to try to
understand it we just haven't you know
we're living it's not because we've
we've had plenty of free time and said
oh shall we talk about Islam Today no
like it just doesn't come up because
autism so it's like it's no but it's
just it's just living Our Lives yeah
it's just what it's just crazy to me
like listening to this stuff like all of
that stuff I will buy all of the science
stuff like Hook Line and sink or you got
me if that is truly if that's in the
Quran in the original copies I do I
believe in God and I believe that he
picks Messengers to to bring things to
to bring knowledge to to pass on to the
Earth and if those things if this video
is accurate that's fascinating and and
proof to me that God exists or Muhammad
was a really Kick-Ass psychic like you
know and I I'm more likely to believe
that that it was gone just based on my
own experiences it's cool that was cool
right Islam one to ten oh my God I'm
playing I'm playing yeah but um all
right yeah thank you guys so much for
watching that's I'm I'm excited to look
more into this [ __ ] this this is not
that [ __ ] but you know what I mean thank
you guys for watching make sure to like
subscribe follow me on Instagram follow
Sunny's mother on Instagram and join the
Discord I have some free Tech talks tips
there for you guys you know I've gotten
60 000 YouTube Subs in three months so I
like to think I know what I'm talking
about a little bit but all right guys so
bye thank you